Hey, this is pretty funny.
Uh, not only does British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson look like Donald Trump, he's also
triggered just as easily by people who disagree
with him.
We're very quickly learning.
Uh, we've been covering the atrocious idea
that is Brexit since the vote back in June,
uh, June 23rd of 2016 I believe it was.
And whether Brexit will or won't ultimately
happen.
We still don't know, although it's not looking
particularly good.
But in any case, one of the most recent sort
of milestones or events in the Brexit saga
was the abandonment of the prime minister
ship by Theresa May and her replacement by
the pro-Brexit conservative Boris Johnson
who looks a lot like Trump and we're learning
is trumpy and in some other ways and things
have not been going particularly well for
Boris Johnson.
Between abandonment of the Tory party by one
MP combined with a number of others just not
agreeing with Boris Johnson's path forward
on Brexit.
He is managing a Brexit that is once again
very much imperiled and increasingly unpopular.
Yesterday Boris Johnson was in Luxembourg
and he was scheduled to do a press conference
with the Prime Minister of Luxembourg and
this is amazing.
They come out of this meeting and there are
two lecterns and two microphones set up for
them and there's a lot of protests that have
got protesters rather that have gathered in
Luxembourg.
And Ah, the prime minister of Luxembourg ends
up just walking Boris Johnson straight out.
Boris Johnson.
Just completely bales on this press conference
they had scheduled.
And then around comes the Luxembourg prime
minister and actually does a little bit of
a press conference by himself.
Check this out.
We're going to have video here of Johnson
walking out with the Luxembourg prime minister
and just walking right on by the lectern and
straight out as a result of the protestors.
And then, uh, the prime minister of Luxembourg
comes back around and actually talks to the
press show.
This is local
pinches as Burns Johnson leaves the Luxembourg
from this restaurant says she's listening.
[inaudible]
well, you can hear the noise that awaited
his departure and that has led to the cancellation
of the news conference, but they won't show
a four to 15 south name as the campus was
on.
You'll see to the left there, the paid him
where they'd to pharmacists would have held
that he's conference, but because of the noise
and the booing and they use her megaphone,
Shaun's from that many British heads pants
among the motto with banners testing oppose
the SPEC spreading fetch.
I think that you may love here from the Luxembourg.
How many stir right now, so let's just, uh,
let's just listen.
She says, let's have you eventually, let's
say if we can.
Thank you very much for listening to me.
I think demonstrating is the right in a democracy
and it is important also to be able to exchange
and to listen to each other.
This
is just amazing.
First of all, how funny is it that Xavier
Battelle, the Luxembourg prime minister walks
out with Boris Johnson?
Like clearly Boris Johnson is fine.
They had their meeting, they walk right by
where the press conference was supposed to
be taking place, walks him right out and then
goes over to the lectern and immediately people
quiet right down and he's able to talk with
no problem whatsoever.
And the hilarious explanation from Boris Johnson's
team was that it was just too loud and rambunctious
because of those protestors, rambunctious
being my word, not theirs admittedly.
And that it would just be really hard for
anybody to hear him if he participated in,
in this press conference.
And yet it seems like it was fine and he would
obviously have been given the opportunity
to speak.
What a brave guy right at Trump wouldn't go
to Britain unless Britain could guarantee
that protests would be quashed and Trump wouldn't
have to be driving around, met by protesters.
And then you've got British Trump and British
prime minister Boris Johnson going to Luxembourg
and just straight up walking away from the
press conference without participating.
And there's a very interesting parallel sort
of developing between Trump and Johnson.
Other than as I've said, they have a very
similar look.
Physically, they're both triggered by protestors
very easily.
They both are increasingly not respected by
other world leaders.
Almost every world leader other than I guess,
you know, some of the authoritarian types,
I guess like Trump or, I don't know if respect
Trump is the right word, but most world leaders
don't respect the president of the United,
the current president of the United States,
fellow European Union leaders increasingly
don't respect Boris Johnson and his harebrained
ideas.
So what hopefully this represents.
We may be starting to see the pendulum sort
of swing back against the nationalist authoritarian,
uh, ideas that have been sort of successfully
masquerading as populism over the last four
to five years.
It's become trendy in some circles.
Hopefully we're starting to see the pendulum
swing back the other way.
One other similarity I'm seeing between Trump
and Boris Johnson is that the United Kingdom
is increasingly seen as a laughingstock internationally
as a result of the endless Brexit fiasco.
Much like the United States under Donald Trump
is also seen as a complete and total laughingstock.
It's actually quite remarkable the similarities
that have developed between the United States
and the UK over the last couple of years.
We'll continue to follow Brexit.
We'll continue to follow Boris Johnson and
the ways in which he is a it increasingly
similar to the president of the United States.
Let me know what you think about him.
Just bailing, walking right by the lectern
and going on out and back to Britain.
I'm on Twitter at [inaudible] pacman.
The show is on twitter@davidpakmanshowandmakesurethatyouarefollowingmeontwitchattwitch.tv
slash David Pakman.
If you have an Amazon prime membership already
at no extra cost, you can subscribe to our
twitch channel with something called twitch
prime.
Amazon prime confers one free twitch prime
membership per month costs you nothing but
it counts as a paid membership for us.
It's like free money that you can give us
at twitch.tv/david
Pacman